The answer is this one. Here is why.
The signature is t^dB mod nB and this was t.
That's what this is. We can use the property of exponents to simplify this.
And now distributing the exponents, we get this. Here we have this term k^eBdB.
Well, these are RSA keys--this is the public and the private key for that modulus.
That is the equivalent to what happens when we do encryption and decryption.
This is equivalent to k because these exponents
end up performing encryption and decryption in the RSA system.
They're designed so that's equivalent to 1, and so we get m^dB times k mod nB,
while this value k--that was the the random value selected by Alice.
She can just divide that out, and by dividing out the k, she gets m^dB mod mB,
which is exactly what she wanted--that's the message m signed by the bank.